[Musique]
Jean-Marc vessousfort merci d'être notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
vous avez été élu dimanche dernier
sénateur du Lot vous êtes membres du
groupe socialiste et encore pour
quelques jours on l'imagine mer de Kor
merci beaucoup d'être notre invité alors
avant de parler de l'actualité avec vous
et de réagir évidemment au nombreux
sujets nos téléspectateurs vous
découvrent on vous découvre pourquoi
vous avez choisi de quitter la mairie de
cor pour venir au Sénat parce que
c'était une nouvelle étape dans mon
engagement politique j'ai été élu
pendant 15 ans désormais et je passerai
le relais dans quelques jours j'ai
toujours été attaché à la liimination
des des mandats dans la durée trois
mandats c'est bien c'est un maire
pendant la campagne qui m'a fait
remonter cet élément il m'a dit tu as
raison le premier mandat c'est pour
apprendre le deuxième c'est pour faire
et le troisème c'est pour transmettre
donc je suis dans cette phase là et
heureux d'avoir eu la confiance des
grands électeurs du Lot et de pouvoir
venir
oui forcément c'est le mandat de MRE est
certainement le plus beau des mandats
c'est un mandat où on peut faire où on
peut agir et donc forcément il y aura un
baissement au cœur lorsque je vais
passer le relais mais je reste
conseiller municipal conseiller
communautaire donc on a toujours une
attention toute particulière pour son
territoire on va évidemment continuer à
parler des maères tout à l'heure parce
qu'ils sont dans l'actualité mais vous
avez donc fait vos premiers pas au Sénat
vous êtes arrivés lundi dernier et puis
hier vous avez assisté à votre première
séance dans l'émicycle puisque c'était
la rentrée quelles ont été vos premières
impressions
d'abord d'assister à cette élection
c'est vrai que Gérard Larcher a
surrassemblé je crois qu'on peut lui
reconnaître qu'il a changé positivement
aussi l'image du Sénat c'est le retour
en tout cas que j'ai du terrain une
instance importante désormais il a
beaucoup parlé du du bicamérisme il a
parlé de la façon sénatoriale j'ai bien
aimé cette expression de de sérieux une
approche pluraliste et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le sénatori de faire de
la politique c'est ça vous confirmez oui
je confirme et puis il a parlé aussi
d'assemblée affective moi je suis très
très attaché à ce qu'on puisse favoriser
la bienveillance une forme d'empathie
c'est vrai que les les élus sur le
terrain c'est les amortisseurs de la
colère et donc c'est important qu'à ce
niveau-là on en est aussi conscience
justement il a parlé des maires des élus
locaux évidemment Gérard Larché on le
sait grand défenseur des territoires et
des élus nous devons remettre les maires
au cœur de la décision a-t-il dit on
imagine que vous le soutenez dans ce
combat il a eu raison d'adresser ce
message au gouvernement oui moi moi vous
savez je suis aussi président de
l'association des élus du lotte
président de l'association des élus
d'occcitanie je suis allé voir
énormément de de communes et je constate
toujours la même chose c'est qu'il y a
un engagement extraordinaire de ces
35000 communes de ces 500000 élus locaux
ils sont pour la plupart des
bénévoles ils s'engagent pour leur
territoire et et et c'est une chance
d'avoir ces élus locaux sur le terrain
surtout qu'on est dans un monde où ça va
très très vite et qui appelle de la
réactivité de laadaptabilité on l'a vu
récemment donc on a besoin de ces élus
locaux et je ne comprends pas qu'on
puisse encore les les remettre en cause
c'est comme si on disait on on a pas
assez on a trop d'associations on n pas
trop d'association tout le monde le sait
mais c'est un petit peu la même chose
qui REM en C le chef de l'État le
gouvernement une administration aussi je
veux dire la loi notre c'était quand
même quelque part la disparition de la
commune puisque il fallait transférer à
des nouvelles intercommunalités qui
devaient être plus grandes on on a voulu
transférer aussi des compétences de de
proximité on a voulu supprimer les
syndicats de communes qui ne sont que
l'expression de la coopération communale
qui existe depuis des années des années
c'est c'est quasiment aussi vieux que la
commune on a eu les les siivu les
sivomes tout ça existait c'était
évidemment des des élus qui avaient
conscience que parfois il n'avait pas la
taille critique et qu'il fallait qu'il
se groupe donc tout ça existait à un
moment donné on a eu l'impression quand
même qu'on voulait supprimer cet échelon
communal ce que je ne comprend toujours
pas surtout dans le contexte actuel vous
avez le sentiment qu'il y a un manque de
considération d'Emmanuel Macron pour les
encore aujourd'hui ou ça s'est amélioré
bah en tout cas on a l'impression qu'il
a parfois un problème avec cet échelon
là il ne reconnaît pas totalement les
associations d'élus on voit bien comment
il a essayé de pratiquer l'évitement je
dirais par rapport à la MF il est venu
au Congrès puis ensuite il a invité les
élus à l'Élysée il est venu faire le
tour du salon mais il n'a pas voulu
venir au Congrès et puis il a des
petites phrases parfois qui sont
incompréhensibles allez considérer
aujourd'hui que l'augmentation de la
fiscalité locale c'est la faute des élus
locaux ENF tout ça n' n'a pas de sens il
faut il faut pas rentrer dans ce genre
de polémique aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
se passe il a une augmentation de la
fiscalité locale parce qu'il y a une
augmentation des bases avec des bases
qui sont indexé sur l'inflation ce qui
est bien normal les élus il doit voter
des budgets en équilibre donc à un
moment donné il faut bien trouver
lorsque vous avez une augmentation des
dépenses il faut bien trouver les
recettes qui vont mais dans le même
temps ce gouvernement augmente depuis 2
ans la dotation globale de
fonctionnement qui est la principale
dotation financière aux collectivités là
où d'autres a commencé par le
gouvernement de François Hollande
socialiste l'AV baissé est-ce que vous
ne reconnaissez pas qu'il fait des
choses pour les élus c'est c'était
évidemment une erreur mais à l'époque
c'était pour participer au redressement
des comptes de la Nation on a vu ce ça
avait donné mais quand il
aussi quand on augmente les dotations de
l'état de 1,2 % et que l'inflation est à
7 % à un moment donné on ne s'y retrouve
pas donc la vérité c'est que les
dotations d'État ont plutôt baissé et ce
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui c'est de
l'aide en fonctionnement moi je préfère
qu'on vienne nous indexer la DGF plutôt
que on nous demande de répondre à des
appels à projet avec une ingénierie qui
coûte parfois très très cher pour avoir
des subventions d'investissement qui
sont importantes mais ce dont on a
besoin aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
vivre les collectivités et ça ça se joue
sur le fonctionnement et la réalité
c'est que la DGF elle est en proportion
moins importante puisque nous devons
faire face à l'augmentation des des
fluides des charges et puis des
compétences nouvelles on va continuer à
parler des maires he puisque les mairres
évidemment qui sont son en première
ligne parfois victime de découragement
alors les Maes ruraux qui étaient réunis
ce weekend ont fait des propositions
pour éviter la crise d'é voocation
regarde le détail avec Alexandre
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour Aran
bonjour Jean-Marc vessousfort bonjour et
Alex les maires ruraux font donc des
propositions pour essayer de rendre plus
attractive la fonction de maire oui car
le mandat de maire attire de moins en
moins nos concitoyens dans 3 ans il y
aura de nouvelles élections municipales
et il pourrait y avoir un nombre de
candidatures insuffisants on parle de
crise des vocations regardez ce que dit
la députée rapporteur d'une mission
d'information parlementaire sur le
statut de l'élu violette spelbot je la
cite il y a plus de démissions plus de
personnes qui n'osent pas s'engager par
peur des violences ou de
l'incompatibilité avec la vie
professionnelle ou ou personnelle donc
le statut de l'élu est un sujet
d'urgence démocratique alors pour
répondre à cette urgence notamment dans
les petites communes l'association des
mares ruraux de France qui s'est réunie
dimanche dernier en congrès a présenté
une série de 35 propositions pour
améliorer le statut de l'élu on peut en
retenir quelques-unes d'abord il
faudrait mettre en place une protection
des élus qui sont en même temps des
salariés sur le modèle de la protection
des représentants du personnel ensuite
créer un article spécifique dans le code
du travail sur le statut de l'élu car
actuellement et bien il y a des mesures
éparpillées et ell ne concernent que les
élus des grandes villes et puis
l'association des mères ruraux propose
aussi que la pension de retraite de
l'élu soit calculée sur un plus grand
nombre de trimestres cotisés et face à
la charge de travail qui augmente pour
nos élus notamment dans les petites
communes avec les réunions qui se
multiplient les déplacements également
et bien l'Association des Maires Ruraux
propose d'augmenter les indemnités des
maires de faciliter leur accès à la
formation et de mettre en place une
meilleure reconnaissance du mandat d'élu
pour faciliter la reprise d'une activité
professionnelle après le mandat alors ce
sont les propositions des Maes mais Alex
il y a déjà des mesures hein qui ont été
prises sur le statut de l'élu c'était
durant le premier quinquen d'Emmanuel
Macron ah oui on ne par pas de Z zé
effectivement dans le cadre de la loi
engagement et proximité en 2019 une loi
sur laquelle avait beaucoup travaillé le
Sénat et bien des mesures ont été pris
ce texte avait par exemple créé une
protection fonctionnelle de l'élu
c'est-à-dire une assurance juridique il
avait également instauré une formation
obligatoire pour les élus des communes
rurales à leur début de mandat car dans
les petites communes il n'y a pas
forcément les services administratifs
pour épauler le maire et puis enfin
cette loi de 2019 avait créé un congé
électif de 10 jours pour tous les
candidats au municipale pour leur
permettre de faire campagne et pour ne
pas freiner certains salariés qui
voudraient s'engager dans la vie locale
Jean-Marc vessousfort est-ce que vous
l'observez sur le terrain cette crise
d'évocation vis-à-vis du mandat de maire
oui bien sûr on a une augmentation des
des démissions je le vois dans mon
département plus importante chez les
conseillers municipaux que chez les
maires parce que les maires ont bien
conscience que ils ont un engagement
devant les électeurs et qui doivent le
tenir donc il faut que ça bouge
effectivement il faut qu'on vienne aider
ces élus ça passe par la la formation ça
passe par le statut de l'élu parce qu'on
a aussi besoin comme élu de gens qui
sont dans la dans la population
active les associations d'élus il
travaillent depuis longtemps là c'est la
MRF l'Association des maires de France
dont je fais
partie fait des propositions depuis
depuis longtemps il faut il faut qu'il y
ait des des réponses parce que
effectivement on va avoir une crise des
des vocations et je le redit ça sera une
vraie difficulté pour ce pays on a
besoin d'interlocuteurs de proximité
c'est une évidence euh vous êtes inquiet
pour 2026 que de nombreuses communes se
retrouvent sans candidat en tout cas il
faut qu'on réagisse non je suis pas plus
inquiet que ça si on arrive à apporter
des réponses en tout cas il faut
favoriser cet engagement là euh vous
savez quand vous êtes dans une commune
de 500 habitants vous avez à votre
disposition un maire 10 conseillers
municipaux et souvent quand vous êtes
dans un grand ensemble lorsque vous êtes
dans un grand ensemble avec 500
habitants ils ont une chance sur deux
d'avoir un concierge c'est c'est ça dont
on a besoin on a besoin d'avoir des
interlocuteurs de de proximité et donc
il faut favoriser ces ces vocations cet
engagement- là la société s'emportera
mieux s'il y a plus d'élus et
concrètement dans une petite commune le
maire est laissé euh un peu face face à
lui-même face à sa charge de travail qui
augmente oui bah il faut d'abord aider
aussi les les collaborateurs des maères
il y a une question sur les les
secrétaires de mairie et il faut pouvoir
mieux les accompagner face à une une
réglementation une lourdeur
administrative qui décourage aussi
beaucoup un niveau de responsabilité qui
est extrêmement important beaucoup de Mr
me disent moi ça ça vaut pas le coup
mais on va le retrouver dans
l'enseignement par exemple avec des des
des professeurs des enseignants qui ne
vouront plus organiser des des voyages
scolaires parce que ça devientne
difficile on voit on voit bien qu'on a
un empilement d'énormes qu'on veut la
sécurité zéro et sur le terrain c'est
souvent intenable donc il faut aussi
revenir à à du concret du terrain à du
pragmatisme avec des services de l'État
qui sont là pour vous accompagner non
pas pour vous rappeler la rigidité de la
loi l'État sur les département doit être
en capacité de pouvoir mettre tout le
monde autour de la table et d'essayer de
trouver des solutions c'est c'est ça
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui on a besoin
de solution on n'a pas besoin de de
rappel à la loi et à la réglementation
l'état accompagne assez les élus
actuellement bah écoutez on a des
interlocuteurs sur le terrain on a euh
une préfette ou un préfet on a des
sous-préfets et des sous-préfettes mais
moi je vois dans département qu'à la
préfette ne reste qu'un an euh comment
voulez-vous qu'elle puisse travailler
elle avait euh pris le temps de mener la
concertation avec les élus on avait fait
la manière des des cahers de doléance on
était venu on avait fait des
propositions et aujourd'hui on a eu un
départ alors on nous a expliquéit que
c'était parce que il fallait euh qu'il y
ait un changement des préfets des
préfettes parce que on allait rentrer
dans une période avec les Jeux
Olympiques avec la Coupe du Monde de de
rugby qu'il fallait que euh voilà voilà
on puisse avoir de la stabilité enfin
moi je ne comprends pas quand un
représentant de l'État reste moins d'un
an aujourd'hui il faut il faut un peu de
de stabilité sur le terrain parce que
c'est ça c'est avec ces interlocuteurs
là que nous allons travailler c'est une
évidence alors on parle de la charge
administrative qui est expliqueraai ce
découragement mais il y a aussi les
violences faites aux élus locaux
finalement cette insécurité qui augmente
pour nos élus oui bien évidemment alors
il y a des propositions de loi qui sont
en cours qui visent à prochaine au Sénat
d'ailleurs mais moi je crois qu'il faut
essayer d'éviter de laisser le maire en
première ligne en fait la vérité c'est
que le maire aujourd'hui c'est celui qui
dit non de plus en plus je vois la façon
dont a été mise en place la le transfert
de la compétence sur l'urbanisme
aujourd'hui le maire est en première
ligne c'est-à-dire c'est lui qui signe
le permis le permis c'est lui qui
annonce le refus et dans le même temps
on sait bien qu'il ne fait que ça en
fait parce que vous avez une telle
rigidité de telles règles
aujourd'huievenir sur leusan qui qui
remonte très très fort
mais les
PL moi j'ai un règlement de PLU qui
faisait 300 pages donc si vous voulez il
est en première ligne mais il n'a pas
les moyens d'assumer cette compétence là
et et donc vous vous êtes obligé de de
désormais d'essayer de les accompagner
pour qu'ils puissent rendre le service
dans les meilleures conditions et qu'ils
ai surtout la possibilité de s'adapter
parce que les territoires sont très
différents vous pouvez pas avoir une
règle qui est la même pour tout le monde
donc ce qu'on demande aussi c'est de
pouvoir être accompagné on nous demande
pour lutter contre l'incendie d'aller
voir les propriétaires privé et qu'il
débroussaille mais enfin là aussi vous
allez au contact c'est pas toujours
facile il faut derrière que l'État
puisse accompagner on a parfois des
dossiers qui sont extrêmement difficile
à régler et donc on a besoin de soutien
et alors très rapidement vous êtes pour
une aggravation des sanctions pénales
sur les auteurs de violence contre les
élus B quand on attaque un élu on
attaque la République donc oui enfin on
peut imaginer que c'est un peu de
dissuasion enfin ça ne suffira pas je
vous le dis ce qui est important c'est
de pouvoir accompagner les élus sur le
terrain sur leur responsabilité et de de
leur donner les moyens d'agir ils ont
pas toujours les Mo moyen d'agir parce
que vous avez un Carca administratif qui
est extrèmement rigide et qui leur
laisse peu de souplesse on va remercier
Alex merci à tout à l'heure Alex et on
va continuer à parler des questions de
sécurité on va voir on va aller
retrouver Éric berger bonjour éc merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef adjoint à la Dépêche du Midi Éric
on va revenir avec vous sur les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron hier sur la sécurité
notamment dans les zones rurales avec
cette carte des nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie oui bonjour Orian en effet
Emmanuel Macron était hier en
lotgaron accompagné de part Gérald
daranin le ministre de l'Intérieur à
tonins exactement un choix qui n'est pas
dû au hasard c'est une petite ville en
territoire rural qui a été marqué ces
dernières années par la fermeture de sa
manufacture de tabac qui a perdu des
emplois des commerces des services
publics on voit bien qu'Emmanuel Macron
voulait s'adresser à cette France rurale
à cette France des des territoires et
donc il a annoncé hier en effet la
création de 238 brigades de gendarmerie
dans le détail c'est 95 gendarmeries
fixes et 143 qui seront des brigades de
mobile le chef de l'État qui a expliqué
dans sa prise de parole à tonins qu'il
fallait sécuriser les territoires ruraux
et que ceuxci avait également des
problèmes de
comme certains quartiers parfois avec
des trafics de drogues avec une hausse
assez nette des violences
intrafamilial des problèmes aussi de
délinquence routière d'où ce plan donc
de déploiement de gendarmerie qui va
s'accompagner par le recrutement de 2100
gendarmes sur tout le
territoire national Emmanuel Macron qui
a aussi profité de l'occasion pour
rappeler que 10000 policiers avaient ces
dernières années
été recrutés ou redéployer dans les
villes donc 300 rien que pour pour
Marseille cette fois-ci les annonces
concernent les territoires ruraux euh le
chef de l'État qui a donc annoncé la
création de ces brigades mobiles c'est
une nouveauté alors qu'est-ce que c'est
tout simplement c'est un camion un
véhicule de gendarme qui va sillonner
les villages et territoires les plus
reculés il y aura un effectif moyen de 6
gendarmes qui seront là pour enregistrer
les plaintes ou pour sécuriser des axes
routier alors dans ce plan de 238
brigades il y en a près de 60 % qui
seront des brigades mobiles dans le
détail on a regardé et constaté que la
région oxitanie était plutôt bien dotée
dans ce plan avec près de 27 nouvelles
brigades sur tous les départements de de
la région et en particulier dans le
lotte le département de votre invité
Jean Marc vessous fort que que je salue
euh il y aura deux nouvelles brigades
qui sont des brigades fixes à saincir
lapupie et à Rocamadour deux communes
touristiques du département où il y a on
l'imagine une forte activité alors je
voulais demander à votre invité ce qu'il
pensez de ces annonces est-ce que ça
vous semble être une une bonne réponse à
ce problème de de délinquence
d'insécurité dans les dans les zones
rurales alors oui la tranquillité
publique est évidemment un élément
d'attractivité très forte en ruralité et
donc on est toujours satisfait de voir
qu'il y a des moyens effectif qui arrive
après je me méfie beaucoup des effets
d'annonce on est dans cette
effervescence sécuritaire et donc on
regardera sur le terrain vous savez
parfois il y a des postes qui sont
ouverts et qui ne sont pas pourvus on
est aussi dans un rétablissement euh
d'un équilibre moi ça fait longtemps que
la gendarmerie me dit on a un petit
problème d'effectif et puis il faut pas
s'arrêter à la question de la
gendarmerie il faut aussi des moyens
pour la justice la réalité c'est que de
la même façon il y a des postes
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas pourvus sur
mon dép appartement la présidente du
tribunal me le rappelit récemment donc
il faut à mon avis que ce soit un
ensemble et que ça soit une action sur
la duré donc nous jugerons dans le temps
mais est-ce que parce que a un autre
juste je vous redonne la parole tout de
suite éc mais juste pour finir sur ce
sujet Emmanuel Macron il a pas choisi le
le tgoron au hasard he c'est un
territoire qui a voté rassemblement
national est-ce que la création de ces
brigades de gendarmerie et remettre des
gendarmes sur le terrain c'est aussi
pour vous un moyen de lutter contre le
rassemblement national
oui parce que euh c'est vrai qu'il y a
euh des citoyens qui ne supportent plus
les incivilités qui ne supportent plus
euh euh tout toutes ces actes
aujourd'hui de de dégradation de de de
biens public ou de biens privés et donc
il faut remettre de la proximité euh ça
a été noté remettre du bleu c'est
souvent ce qu'on dit oui il faut de la
présente d'autant plus que les les
gendarmes sont sont vraiment dans la vie
dans le dans dans dans le territoire et
que ce sont des interlocuteurs
importants pour les maires mais euh il
faut aussi travailler les relations avec
la justice je salue les efforts qui ont
pu être faits pour qu'il y ait un
meilleur dialogue entre les procureurs
et les maires je pense que les les élus
peuvent être un soutien important pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses et donc
il faut là aussi qu'on soit en capacité
de travailler ensemble et qu'il y ait
des moyens pour la gendarmerie mais
qu'il a aussi des moyens pour la justice
et qu'on soutienne les maères parce que
je rappelle que les maires sont souvent
ceux qui accompagnent ces politiques on
va venir les chercher pour mettre à
position des bâtiments c'était ce qui
s'est passé dans le loté Garon maire
explique aussi que il va falloir loger
les jambesarmes et souvent c'est la
collectivité qui intervient d'où
l'importance aussi d'aider les maires
sur le terrain avec une augmentation des
moyens en fonctionnement Éric je je vous
donne la parole pardon vous avez une
question sur une autre problématique he
qui concerne toujours les élus en effet
qui concerne vraiment pleinement les
territoires ruraux et on le sait bien
ici dans dans la région Occitanie c'est
celui de la désertification
médicale concrètement ce qui a été fait
ces derniers mois est-ce que ça vous
semble suffisant qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait concrètement pour Ben ramener
des des médecins des médecins
spécialistes dans des départements comme
le lot ou des départements ruraux où on
a des médecins qui partent à le retraite
qui ne sont pas remplacer des habitants
qui sont obligés de faire des kilomètres
pour aller voir le le spécialiste
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous vous
proposeriez aujourd'hui c'est la France
qui est un désert médical il vous reste
quelques oasis dans certaines
région la santé c'est une compétence
d'État et forcé de constater que c'est
un fiasco il y a pas eu de prévision de
planification on se retrouve à une
vitesse folle sans médecins libéraux sur
le territoire il faut un an de un an
pour avoir un rendez-vous chez un
dentiste les spécialistes c'est devenu
très compliqué et qu'est-ce qu'on
constate sur le terrain que la réaction
elle vient souvent des élus qui mettent
en place des maisons de santé des
centres de santé moi-même j'ai travaillé
avec une clinique privée euh dans une
ville proche et puis on va mettre en
place 10 oftalmo sur le territoire le
département du Lot qui n'en avait plus
que trois donc il faut là aussi qu'on
mette les gens autour de la table et
qu'on essaie de trouver des solutions
très vite et je le dis ça ne passera pas
par de la planification par un conseil
de la de de de de la nationale de de de
de la refondation enfin il faut
aujourd'hui
agir il n'est pas le temps d'imaginer le
service il faut aujourd'hui le pratiquer
sur le terrain c'est ça dont on a besoin
alors les solutions il y en a
certainement beaucoup elles sont
plusrielles mais en tout cas c'est vrai
que si demain vous avez pas une offre de
santé adaptée sur votre territoire on va
manquer d'attractivité c'est une
évidence merci RC berger merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on était ravi de
vous retrouver comme à chaque fois on
regarde la Une de La Dépêche du Midi qui
dans son édition du Lot etgaron revient
bien sûr sur ce déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron Macron annonce 238 brigades c'est
à la Une de votre votre journal merci
ERC berger et à très vite un dernier mot
pour parler de politique du parti
socialiste Jean-Marc vessoussort vous
êtes un proche de Carole Delga la
présidente de la région xistan donc pas
un fervant défenseur de la nuub telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui on l'imagine
je voudrais faire réagir à cette lettre
qui a écrit Olivier fort hier soir
lettre à l'ensemble des responsables de
l'ANUP il fait une croix il met fin au
faux suspense sur la liste commune aux
européennes il y en aura pas et puis il
a cette phrase il est l'heure de sortir
de ce clué d'au politique pour savoir
qui a tué laanupe nous sommes une
coalition personne n'a sal igné sur
personne personne n'a s'essuyer les
pieds sur le collectif est-ce que vous
approuvez cette lettre et ce message
vous savez aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
doit rassembler la gauche et ça doit sur
faire sur certaines bases en fait entre
la gauche qui est arrivée au
gouvernement et puis gauche que je
qualifierai deextrême gauche ce qui nous
différencie c'est le respect de la
démocratie le respect scrupuleux de la
démocratie je pense qu'il faut partir de
là moi je préfère l'engagement civique
que la désobéissance civile je pense
qu'il faut faire attention dans nos
attitudes si le Sénat a pris de la place
c'est aussi parce que l'Assemblée
nationale souffre du spectacle qui est
donné moi je l'ai entendu sur le terrain
il faut cet esprit de responsabilité et
donc il faut pas que nous soyons que des
lanceurs d'alerte il faut que nous
soyons au travail pour le coup c'est ce
qu'essaie de faire Carole delgaard je
crois pouvoir dire que c'est une voix
qui compte aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
là la démarche d'Olivier fort est la
bonne est-ce qu'il a raison de taper un
peu du point sur la table oui et en même
temps d'appeler au rassemblement mais je
veux dire est-ce que la nus existé à un
moment donné on voit bien que il reste
encore des partis des chapelles il va
falloir dépasser tout ça avec une ligne
assez claire fa mettre fin dépasser tout
ça c'est mettre fin écoutez euh il ne
faut pas perdre l'idée de rassembler la
gauche ça c'est important avec ceux qui
veulent participer à un mouvement qui
respecte je le redis encore est-ce qu'il
faut la rassembler avec la France
insoumis c'est la question mais une
partie peut-être je vous dis ce qu'il
FAA la différence c'est que est-ce qu'on
respecte nos institutions démocratiques
et notamment la démocratie locale moi je
vois parfois des prises de position de
de certains au niveau national qui
viennent sur mon territoire et qui
m'expliquent que le projet que nous
avons pensé euh ne ne va pas dans le bon
sens à un moment donné on a un projet de
de de voie verte qu'on a développé
l'ensemble des maires le long de cette
voie verte ils sont favorables il faut
faire confiance au territoire on peut
pas toujours remettre en cause des
règles qui ont été prises de manière
démocratique donc là-dessus on peut
trouver euh un lien qui nous rassemble
et puis ensuite évidemment faudra
travailler avec un programme faudra
aussi avoir des personnalités parce
qu'on sait désormais qu'avec le système
de la présidentielle il nous faut un ou
une leader et c'est tout car delg peut
être à même d'incarner cette ce
rassemblement jusqu'à la présidentielle
je disque c'est une voix qui compte elle
a été la président de région la mieux
élu de France dans un contexte qui
n'était pas facile parce que il fallait
fusionner m pérené et Lang crousillon
langodo crousillon dont on disait qu'il
allait basculer à l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été le cas elle a
été la mieux élue donc il y a un travail
qui est fait et elle raison il faut un
travail de terrain aujourd'hui il faut
essayer de construire quelque chose
honnêtement je pense que les les
citoyennes et les citoyens et les gens
de gauche se moque complètement de
savoir la nuupèe les petites phrases je
Jef je on est vraiment en dehors de tout
ça je vous le dis sur le terrain donc ça
ça ne m'intéresse pas vraiment merci
Jean-Marc bessousp merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure